but the point is the following here's
the point
you have no idea how excited i am right
now i love it let me tell you why i'm so
excited right now let me tell you why
i'm so excited right now
i said this to jose jose and i was jose
gaitar and i were exchanging texts
yesterday was just this has been a
special last four days
i am so excited because in life
here's how this works
you go to a bar
you get into a fight
say you're a tough guy
and you push your weight around you beat
one guy up
i don't know you beat another guy up oh
you beat another gap so after a month or
two months or three months you beat
everybody up and you're the tough guy at
that bar there's one guy that's sitting
in the corner quietly yeah he ain't
saying [ __ ] yeah and then one day you
pick on him it's over and you pick on
that guy and then you realize
you're officially not the toughest guy
in the bar yeah you're gonna get your
ass handed to you he's gonna publicly
embarrass you
i was in the army
and we in our boot camp we were all
fighting okay and it was a circle and we
would that's how we get rid of our
testosterone we're fighting so i'm
fighting and i'm be and i have no
cloutified i've never done uf i've never
done mma nothing i'm not going to take
on nothing
so my nose has been broken one too many
times right so i'm fighting off i'm
gonna lose you so i feel so good i'm
like oh look look let me tell you who i
am yeah so the reputation i got right
a guy shows up in the circle there's 200
guys that are wanting to fight and one
by one
guy shows up he's five six five seven
yeah maybe 130 pounds he says do you
mind
i said what do you mean he said i'd love
to fight you
i said i don't want to hurt you yeah of
course
so and this is before ufc so you didn't
know who knew how to fight back nowadays
you don't want to fight because anybody
knows how to fight them for sure if they
say do you mind you shoot him
do you mind
something that's the scariest [ __ ]
what are you saying 200 people please
tell me this isn't felix but you got no
felix can't fight anybody phyllis just
talks [ __ ] and we have to fight for
felix no that's a guy this guy comes and
he says can i fight you we fight let me
tell you took him six seconds what
ethnicity was he no no he was a
uh he was a black uh
guy 18 year old black kid like me and he
was from florida or ohio yeah and i say
in all of jump bam i'm on the floor i'm
like dude
so what does it matter with you he says
i'm the florida state champion in high
school so why don't you tell me
something come on this is why i thought
it would have ruined the surprise
so i said
so the point is the following in life
you're eventually going to realize who's
out there today the market is starting
to tell you stop bullying us
people are waking up elon musk is fed up
and he's done with these bullies and now
he's bullying bullies good guys like
rogan are bullying bullies guys like
bill maher are sick of it bill think
about bill maher is sick who's bill
maher are you
i sent something to jon stewart two days
ago because his show did you guys hear
about john stewart's show yeah he's
reading what i said to john stuart on
twitter john stewart's show comes out
and they he tank they only have forty
thousand listeners and he sends a tweet
he sent right to read his tweet he says
holy [ __ ] just think how bad actually
click on his tweet and then go back
because you have to see what he's
tweeting holy [ __ ] just think how bad
it'll get in season two and they uh
upped our episode order wtf ryden it's
the he gets 40 000 viewers and then
here's what i said john you're one of
the best to ever do it if not the goat
however here's some feedback if you're
open to it carry on if you're not i feel
you have a unique voice i feel the
market is filled with those on the left
and the right who are 100 loyal to their
party and not america click on it so i
can read the rest of it yeah click on
that go below it
i said i feel 20 percent the market who
was in the middle is sick of it the 40
on the left or the right who doesn't
think the other side gets anything right
we both know that's not true and semi
arrogant to believe that take a comedian
entertainer like yourself russell brand
joe rogan bill maher dave chappelle and
a few others who use comedy to take
shots at people on both sides of the
aisle what gets annoying is when they
you only pick on one side and play
politics loyal to the people whose
birthday parties and functions you
attend i believe you have an opportunity
to help unite america bill maher has
gained new audience because he's calling
out his own side you hesitate to do that
for some reason it could be fear or
comfort zone or something else not sure
you were the goat of the original
political satire interviews you cornered
people stephen colbert tried to be you
but he missed the mark bill bilmar has
gained a new ton of followers because
he's shown he can reason he can call out
bs so much as you may not like this
message but maybe taking a bit of
responsibility and owning up to it could
change the game not selling out stay
core to your values and principles but
strengthen them by seeing flaws in them
they may not be 100 right again carry on
if this was a waste of your time to read
perfect there you go there you go i see
some of these guys and i say dude maybe
you're wrong yeah and guys like him only
have forty thousand five forty thousand
listeners how to help do you realize
rogan rogan has if we do them at forty
thousand times send us four hundred
thousand times a hundred four million
rogaine has three hundred times more
listeners than jon stewart
not three times folks
300 times more than jon stewart
just because you're worried about those
parties you're not 100 it's pathetic to
me how much do you think jon stewart is
kicking himself for giving up the daily
show for whatever this thing is i don't
even know what the hell that is but even
who's the noah guy i mean trevor noah
barely barely talks talk [ __ ] like i
think i saw one clip where he was
actually like you know joe biden's you
know messing up and hope trump i can't
believe he actually said it but like you
said to patrick uh
like when i see bill maher i'm like whoa
is he shifting my cousin mike was like i
think he's shifting because he knows
nobody wants to listen to your [ __ ]
a lot of people are right
have any of your friends from uh
the right gone closer to the left
anybody right of center going farther
left oh my god
no no no no listen to what he said i
agree with him people who were on the
far right who have gone a little bit
more left yes i agree he's not saying
they went from right to left
he's saying you were far far right and
let's just say you were
right of mega yeah and you're kind of
like yeah i'm kind of going to be a
little bit more here and i'm going to be
i don't know pick a name i'm going to be
more like desantis or i'm going to be
more like this so i have seen that
happen where people are making that
shift yeah but a lot of people who were
on the far left have gone to the left oh
yeah and now in the center slightly
right yeah that's the part i'm almost
seeing like if this is the pendulum
some people are going and they're kind
of going here
people are trying to i saw something the
other day they had i can't even remember
the article but they had rogan's face on
with ann coulter and desantis and trump
and something and i'm literally these
people right-wing
like he's
he is an la
liberal i mean that's what he was at
least uh you know what i mean like it's
all
it's all it is there it is yeah it's
that one msnbc
with these people because he's a
right-wing hate monger well that's what
they're saying there which is like
they canceled lives of tick tocks yeah
they canceled it let me remind you this
is the guy that endorsed bernie sanders
yeah for president of the united states
and now he's a right-winger because uh
he's big because he has the most
successful show and adam libs of uh tick
tock is just uh uh it's really tweeting
that's right they make videos themselves
retweeting uh teachers that are speaking
in front of a camera in their own house
or their office and this she's just
reposting it and they canceled her is
that is that insane and then the same
girl that wrote this article went out on
cnbc and cried
cried on air because she had such a hard
time because people were doxxing her and
coming and there were mobs and what does
she do she goes to this girl's house
right to her family's house starts
banging on the door
and then proceeded to dox her and reveal
her identity
and the girl who ran the account is now
in hiding yeah she put her address in
that she did exactly what that's
thinking this is what i'm trying to say
to you this doesn't work man no you
can't bully for too long
somebody really shows up and you have to
really straighten up your act every kid
learns this some learn it at a young age
some learn it at a teenage age but every
kid learns
some companies it takes them a while to
learn a lot we start off as a small
insurance company we had 60 agents and
we grew now we have licensed 35 000
agents 20 000 active agents and we've
grown but every day i'm still you know
there's there's got to be that fear of
even though you got this it's market
it's competition you can't be arrogant
about it if you enjoyed this short clip
click over here to watch another short
clip and if you want to watch the entire
episode the entire podcast click here
[Music]